the cool thing about that is what we've
had great discussions right with Jeff
John's over there at DC phenomenal Dan
it's a this is a really really fun cool
time for DC right now because they're
really in a process of truly world
building and building out right and
we're seeing that right with Wonder
Woman and Aquaman we have some few
surprises down the line so what we
decided to do was actually create a
scenario where black Adam is having his
standalone movie right Captain Marvel
Shazam will have his standalone movie
and then that way we're building our
world up that way and then we can come
together at some other point so we have
we have a surprise for Black Adam coming
up I can't tell you hey everybody do you
smell the movie that the rock is cooking
so this explains a little bit about
what's going on with the Black Adam and
Shazam characters Henry Cavill also just
did an interview where he explained what
the future of his Superman is going to
be confirming that there would be a
future for all you wondering what's
gonna be happening with Superman after
Justice League like what their big plans
are for him in the DC Universe whatever
you want to call the film universe now I
know it technically it's not supposed to
be called the DC EU but I'll start with
the Superman stuff just because that's
justice Lee coming up really quickly
Black Adam is a little further down the
road I'll explain that in the context of
Shazam in that big surprise that the
rock said that they're cooking up for
the movie but I'm still doing the movie
ticket giveaway I'll explain that at the
end of the video make sure you subscribe
to get everything the World Series is
this week so the schedule is gonna be a
little bit crazy make sure you click
that Bell to enable alerts so you don't
miss any of the videos so the past
couple of weeks the entire cast has been
on the press two or four Justice League
they did a big preview of about a half
an hour of the movie in China you guys
have probably heard about obviously they
only saw a half hour or that people were
talking about Green Lantern stuff but
one thing's been notably absent for the
last year or so and that's been Henry
Cavill saying anything about what's
going on with his character what his
opinions are about the movies that
they've done so far so I'm just gonna
read what he said even if Marvel didn't
exist we'd struggle there was a style
they were going for an attempt to be
different and look at things from a
slightly different perspective which
hasn't necessarily
yes it's made money but it hasn't been a
critical success it hasn't given
everyone that sensation that superheroes
should give the viewer I feel like right
now the right mistakes have been made
and they haven't been pandered - and we
can start telling the stories in the way
that they need to be told it's even
better to come back from a mistake or a
stylistic error into the correct Bane
because it will make it seem that much
stronger Wonder Woman was the first step
in that right direction so that sort of
Henry cobbles take on the stuff that
they've done so far in the backlash
against the last couple of movies but I
think a lot of people were taking that
to mean that he was throwing people
under the bus that's not the case he's
just saying the like hey look there was
a lot of controversy over the last
couple of films it just gives us an
opportunity to try and recalculate some
things and truly do these characters
justice to make as many Justice League
puns as possible so then he sort of gets
to the meat of the future of the
Superman character where he says any
success within the superhero universe
especially within DC is wonderful
talking about Wonder Woman because I
want to keep telling the Superman story
selfishly that works for me so he's just
making the joke that any big success
within DC Comics also helps propel his
character forward too so he's selfish in
that he wants the other films to succeed
so that his character will be given the
opportunity to succeed as well because
you have to imagine like worst case
scenario they try to recast everybody
but this is just confirmation that he's
going to continue playing Superman and
what I think will happen is is they'll
wait a little while before doing the
direct Man of Steel sequel I've said a
number of times I want patty Jenkins to
take a crack at that but she's really
busy with Wonder Woman - so they might
actually put somebody else on the
project but there are a lot of rumors
that they might try to tie him into the
black atom movie tangentially so that's
still a rumor it's still wide open for
Theory crafting but what the rock has
been saying about the black atom movie
is that now they're totally separate
Shazam and black atom Shazam will get
his origin story movie they have the
director they have a script they have
their actor Zachary Levi I'll post a
link to that video that I did at the end
of this but his comments make it sound
like Black Adam will not appear in that
movie and they won't actually go
head-to-head
until a later date after they've
developed the characters a little and I
think that's probably a good idea you
can do a much more bright hopeful movie
with Shazam just because that's what the
character flows from you can do a darker
movie for Black Adam just because his
character is so dark but if you haven't
seen it the rock has already made a lot
of comments about his character where
he's coming from the conversations that
he's actually had with Geoff Johns and
what's come out of that and it gives you
a couple ideas of where they're gonna
take his character in that first movie
so this is that clip then I'll explain
what that probably means for his movie
you referred to Black Adam as a hero but
he's a villain what's that mean for the
movie it's really in our interpretation
and who we deemed a hero yes of course
Black Adam in the mythology is a villain
or he could be considered an antihero or
to some he's a hero to some who have a
black heart like me again I loved the
backstory that he started off as a slave
and he was held down and I think when
that kind of backstory about a man is
held down and he rises up out of that to
become greater and then dealing with the
conflict the pain of losing his family
it's dark but it also adds to the
gravity and adds to the weight of the
story so what does it mean for the movie
it means that the movie is gonna be
fantastic and it means that it's gonna
be badass and it means to me so right
off the bat him talking about how he
doesn't see his character as a villain
more of an antihero who was turned dark
by the killing of his family
it sounds like we'll actually see that
happen during the blackout a movie will
get a version of that origin story
that'll set him up is more of a tragic
figure that other people feel bad for
like Shazam tries to redeem him Superman
would feel bad for him in present day I
understand the tragedy that has befallen
you and why you feel the need to act so
strongly against people who you think
would hurt your own home country of
conduct he's not a mustache twirling
villain who just flies around looking to
kill other people because he enjoys
killing he stays relatively local to
conduct he only kills people that he
sees as threats to his own people like
he rules it with an iron fist dr. doom
and lot beriah and the Marvel Universe
is a good
log for that but in the way you jumped
forward and backwards in time during the
Wonder Woman movie they'll probably do
the same thing in Black Adam because so
many people love that Wonder Woman was a
period film they might also try that
with black Adam and because the rock is
such a big international star you don't
necessarily have to put Superman in and
just to get people into the theaters but
what they might try to do is Wonder
Woman style put some bookends on it they
connect it to the larger DC Universe in
modern-day so you can go back in time
tell that classic story Scorpion King
shout out if anybody remembers that film
with the rock and then you can still
have some special Superman Justice
League related stuff without having him
overtake the film like spider-man
homecoming an Iron Man where they're
just like a little bit of those other
really big a-list characters but they
might tie some of the modern Superman
related events in the DC Universe to
black Adams reemergence in present day
like what is he doing right now during
this big Kryptonian invasion obviously
he's alive in the universe somewhere
maybe he just doesn't feel like this
affects him because it's happening in
the United States it's happening so far
away from his home country but because
there's so much further ahead in the
development of the Shazam movie I think
that'll probably drop first maybe the
wizard makes a reference to something
really bad happening with one of his
former apprentices then you go back to
the Black Adam movie but obviously in
the present day of Black Adam in Shazam
that will take place after the events of
Justice League unless you're talking
about the flashback portions like when
you go back 5,000 years to the origin of
Black Adam so what will happen is is
there was also a bunch of titans casting
news there's a rumor now that Roy Harper
is actually going to be a character on
Titan season 1 so I'll do a video for
all those new characters tomorrow but
there's a new flash episode tonight I'll
post my video after it airs there's a
new round of that Justice League ticket
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video congratulations to the winner
from last week London Buckley please
private message me so I can get your
contact details click here for tonight's
flash episode and click here to learn
all about Zachary Levi Shazam thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight